bienvenidos a esta edición de más andino
antes de venezuela en este programa
haremos una radiografía del sistema de
salud venezolano y evaluaremos la
situación de los hospitales y
mostraremos los obstáculos que
atraviesan principalmente los pacientes
con enfermedades crónicas por la falta
de acceso a los tratamientos también
hablaremos sobre las implicaciones que
ha tenido la reciente orden del
presidente nicolás maduro de acabar con
lo que denominó mafias hospitalarias a
su juicio responsables de la escasez de
insumos en los centros públicos de salud
según un reciente informe de la encuesta
nacional de hospitales actualmente en
venezuela el desabastecimiento de
insumos médicos ronda el 70 por ciento
aunado a ello en los centros de salud
pública más grandes del país en promedio
sólo dos quirófanos están operativos
además las infraestructuras están
deterioradas ascensores dañados falta en
camillas y la mayoría de los equipos
básicos de atención también fallan el
vicepresidente de la academia nacional
de medicina considera que el sistema
hospitalario colapsó el déficit de camas
ronda por ciento pero en algunos
hospitales como el jm de los ríos el
principal de atención de niños del país
alcanza el 75 por ciento
denuncia además que 80 por ciento de los
tomógrafos y resonadores en venezuela no
funcionan en venezuela el 60 por ciento
de los hospitales tienen déficit
medicamento de todo tipo pero cuando
hablamos de fases agudas como un infarto
como una angina de pecho la diabetes el
paciente que va al hospital no consigue
esos medicamentos y terminan engrosando
una larga lista de espera o en el peor
de los casos muerte por una patología
que puede ser prevenible y tratable las
fallas en los servicios públicos agrava
aún más la situación
60% de los hospitales no tiene agua de
manera continua y en el año 2021 se
registraron 141 fallecimientos de
pacientes atribuidos a los cortes de
energía eléctrica según la encuesta
nacional de hospitales divulgada por
asociaciones vinculadas al gremio médico
los pacientes no sólo sufren por la
precariedad y el deterioro de los
hospitales tampoco tienen la atención
médica oportuna y necesaria en el caso
de los pacientes renales cuya esperanza
de vida se vio reducida luego que hace
cinco años el gobierno suspendiera el
programa de procura de órganos para
transplantes en el país por no poder
garantizar entre otras cosas los
inmunosupresores el pasado noviembre
nicolás maduro anunció la reactivación
de los trasplantes sin embargo en la
práctica esto no se ha regularizado
céspedes tiene 32 años y desde hace 10
estar a la espera de un trasplante de
riñón un proceso de diálisis que le ha
dejado múltiples cicatrices en su cuerpo
soy una joven de 32 años pasé 33 y me
siento una viejita
para caminar la movilidad me duele mucho
las rodillas las caderas
este tratamiento así como me ayuda
también deteriora mi cuerpo y solamente
nos queda depender de la máquina y
y ver cómo mueren mis compañeros los
niños
la verdad como regla yo les vio morir a
su hermano mientras esperaba un
trasplante el pasado 8 de febrero su
hijo ángel de 15 años también falleció
estuvo cuatro años esperando un
trasplante de riñón que nunca se le pudo
realizar la ong y prepara familia
contabiliza 71 menores de edad
fallecidos en el área de nefrología del
hospital jm de los ríos desde el 2017
cuando el gobierno suspendió el programa
de procura de órganos no poder
garantizar los inmunosupresores
cinco años después la falla persiste
la situación también es crítica para los
pacientes oncológicos cuya vida está en
riesgo por la falta de acceso a sus
tratamientos los pacientes han salido a
protestar en varias oportunidades
exigiendo el suministro de medicamentos
de alto costo que no pueden pagar por
sus propios medios a la situación en los
últimos años ha empeorado muchísimo
las pacientes desesperadas muriendo en
sus casas a punta igualada pues
increíbles
un cáncer que de repente era
diagnosticado grado 2 pues hace
metástasis rápidamente porque no hay
posibilidades de nada y muy pocos
hospitales horitas es que están
nuevamente como abriendo citas porque
con el tema del cob y tampoco había su
acción entonces eso ha empeorado pero
muchísimo toda la situación de los
pacientes con cáncer en venezuela son
muchos los médicos venezolanos que
trabajan en la administración pública
dedicados a la atención con los pocos
insumos con los que cuentan o suelen
solicitar a los familiares lo necesario
para atender a los pacientes a mediados
de abril el gobierno de nicolás maduro
inició una persecución contra los
trabajadores de la salud por solicitar
material médico-quirúrgico para atender
a los enfermos los denominó mafias
hospitalarias desde entonces la
federación médica venezolana ha
contabilizado al menos 40 médicos
detenidos una acción que califica como
injustificada contra un personal que
elabora sin insumos y que gana un
salario menor a 100 dólares mensuales
el presidente de la república
con la mafia debería cambiar a todos los
directores de los hospitales de
venezuela porque a quién le han
entregado el dinero desde hace por lo
menos 15 años quedan los directores el
médico el equipo de salud no tiene nada
que ver con la cuestión administrativa
de los hospitales en el 2016 el
parlamento declaró la emergencia
humanitaria compleja en venezuela del
2019 la pandemia empeoró la situación si
bien es cierto que la actividad
comercial se ha reactivado en venezuela
los hospitales siguen siendo un reflejo
de un país en decadencia y los problemas
estructurales siguen sin solución hasta
aquí en esta edición de las en vino
desde venezuela recuerden que pueden
sintonizarnos a través de www punto
frente 4 punto com
[Música]